and
canaro Kate
Ando Kate
andoo and Kate
Kate Kate
and the
ice
[Music]
[Applause]
andar
AAR
AAR citizens of the reject Nation it is
time for Monarch Legacy of canaro hey
John are you ready I'm ready to watch
the show to get to the holer I'm so
excited it's about time guys leave a
like on this video also subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction for I think
the finale is up thank you to preer for
helping us edit down these highlights
I'm trying not to do my Johnny D but I
feel myself descending into it and uh
full hour re we know how to make the
audience really want to syn up with your
own copy of Monarch are available at
patriarch I feel like he does a few
words at a time this is Cadence and now
we cover several things over there
highlight some watchs include right no
more wasting time let's uh let's unpack
this Hollow
Earth oh it's a it's a beautiful day
it's a beautiful day me and your uncle
Lee we'll see when he gets back from his
trip where's he going Uncle
it's classified you know that it's top
secret army Explorer stuff
right is it dangerous can't say well
we're doing it for the good of the world
you're not trying to keep everybody safe
from what guess what we do is always a
little dangerous well you know all about
that right danger is your middle name
but I'll be back really soon in fact my
lucky pocket knife
hey I know we said said we were going to
look into getting you one when you were
older so I'm not actually giving this to
you
okay I want you to keep it safe for me
okay just until I'm back never open
it that's what he uses to shave his
pencils really might have been I mean he
had like a single blade I bet he kept it
damn what a cool mobile home can't get
over it I know man like a sea of mobile
homes you did good swap she' be proud
shame she can't be here to see it she'd
miss all this running around doing nine
jobs at once yeah doing all of them
better than any nine of us can do one
it's okay you both look great in those
jackets and that's enough for me so this
is post her dying
right I guess or sometimes these cut
backs to the timelin conf the [__] out
of me and this is a great tracking shot
by the way her yeah being taken by the
by the roach things you don't have to do
this there's plenty of qualified
candidates we can I don't know it's
plenty of Expendables no I'm not going
to ask anybody to do something that I
wouldn't do myself I do it all the time
did you ever manage to get that jeep out
of
third go to
hell we are
[Laughter]
friends oh my God mon arheimer
operation hourglass is the culmination
of nearly two decades of project
monarchs work Brandy sha human Discovery
connaissance Territory between us and
them that orange suit is the
doctor explorers a place that will
redefine our understanding of the entire
planet I really like this historical
fiction aspect it's cool to have an
inverse of a space
[Music]
launch of a cut a he's
excited this will explain how
Shaw aged in a decelerating way a man
those boyish good looks Kennedy can have
outter space and all the big rocks
floating in it we're about to plant our
flag interesting vessel in under
space under space we're going to plant
our flag where no one can see it thing
is the tunnel is too unstable for us to
enter the only thing which makes it pass
is exposition is a Titan yes I learned
this from godilla versus Kong what's
that we have Titan look as we did on
bikini at all we lure the Titan with a
promise of a meal Titan's coming for our
pain but
Jesus that's a big one yeah maybe you
guys should expand the perimeter a
little bit 4000 ft but the tunnel
between here and there stabilizes as
they move through
woo so rather than unleash Helen Kansas
we cut bait there it goes it's going
home and we sneak in behind them sneak
in behind the dinner bell this seems
like a terrible
plan very
dangerous all right and uh see you next
week come on come on come
on
oh a
surge oh snap this is some cool sci-fi
horror right
here what frequency is
this is it
magnetized which Titan is this going to
be or is it just like the vortex pool of
going into the hollow Earth
wowe that's how you know dramatic shit's
going down in the 50s when you hold your
hat
are they all going to get sucked in yeah
what's good maybe they're all those
people down there from the Godzilla X
Kong
trailer oh
no oh no PO God snap
dude a front row seat in the back of the
Air Stream
it's like being on the Gravitron
yeah gentlemen we had made history
did
America just love the Aesthetics and the
costumes more in the 50s the props and
stuff the brightness of the day dealing
with so much unknown [__] you're just
like let's just go in there I think we
have the technology I feel like be like
years in the making to they do
everything before you decid to just go
in you know that's enough you know we we
we got at least maybe enough to get into
the door that that's enough go with that
take them like years to figure out how
to get to the moon would you want to
drop like a probe down there first yeah
you don't want to just like we got
this Quinton
Tarantino wiggle your big to
where am I Tokyo we had to airlift you
out of Kazakhstan we had to drift here
everything at the reactor
plant it went terribly wrong history
repeats itself does sure he imploded the
Rifts and the whole thing collapsed in
on
itself
oh that's a good last time
on oh rest Tim and the local showed up
you've done enough I'm lucky I didn't
end up in a kic prison I love you Tim a
lot of good people didn't make it out
sure
May I'm sorry the legacy of Tim's
glasses yeah man they're always
surviving any destruction that comes way
scratched they're made of
Secrets Hollow Earth titanium so where
do we start looking for them they didn't
make it we finished Shaw's Le Shaw died
doing what he loved that's what you
always think he augmented a moment of
global crisis for this organization that
we have barely begun dealing with and he
got your sister and friend killed thank
you for your help but your time in the
world has come to an end you're written
off the show all these jokes back in
Tara then he gives us a completely
different type of performance best
performance given yet there has to be
something I can do there is live a
Legacy of
canaro oh
[Music]
Mom All Is
Lost we are in the dark night of Soul
people I can tell I feel it it's a good
canaro scene did good
job Hollow
[Music]
Earth it's like the Spike Lee shot but
he's on the ground okay so God what is
the scientist lady's name she's got to
be here yeah she's got to be here she
got to be here at alive young and hot at
alive I feel it oh yeah unchanged by
[Music]
time
andar this looks like The Lovely Bones
oh didn't you just do a a reaction to on
the channel I did
oh look out this is wonderfully lit yeah
love the Pearl essence of
it welcome to the inside of an acid
tab is this Hollow Earth I don't know
maybe some in between Place feels yeah
this feels
different
oh
whoa we can't stay here we got to get
out of this place we got to move fast
you got to hold my hand and move exactly
where I move okay now come on I
completely buy her like overwhelmed yeah
dear in the headlights look right
there oh this is exciting yeah this is
sweet wow
whoa lightning
underfoot oh is that what was attacking
in the 50s 60s yeah it must have been
what was feeding
back mayy moth yep definitely we're in
the quantum realm yes time doesn't apply
here Rift closes it leaves some kind of
electrical charge or something it
affects your vision it goes off like a
lethal static shock static shock how do
you know that because I've been down
here may on a recon mission oh we're in
it may in what we're in their world the
Titans so the how did I get here cleared
the space and then I hit the timer she
must have turned around and come back
inside oh my God she followed me back W
no no listen oh my God so this is Hollow
Earth I guess so may she's down here
somewhere I know that is she alive she's
just a fried skeleton she's still
smoking but with perfect
hair you got to do everything exactly as
I say and I can keep you safe you
understand we are going to repopulate
the human race here starting a
new
what's cool is that in when we went here
in Godzilla versus Kong it was all like
a big CGI landscape I like how this
feels all tangible and practical effects
look like they actually shot it
somewhere it could be a studio set but
it's still feels convincing yeah it
doesn't feel as much like a volume or
something and the inability of project
Monarch to ascertain the cause of the
catastrophe the Department of Defense
has ordered no further funds be
allocated to project project Monarch God
every step forward is two steps back a
network of portals connecting to a
hidden realm of monsters it sounds
insane in a word sounds like an or Wells
broadcast bring one up right show what a
real catastrophe looks like and what
then hope it's smaller than Godzilla as
I talk about Godzilla they are Bast in
Green Glow symbolism I can't let it go
pck I won't I'm going rogue your boy's
already lost a mother now an uncle do
not take his father away too all what he
does sound
advice and he rushes to Burger King I am
starved my problems in grief yeah I
would love if they actually made that a
thread just eating to cope they should
why not yeah is a great way to connect
it well I'm not a science guy so it's uh
I got time actually you don't what are
you talking about I told you I've been
here before and I made it back oh we're
finally going to learn the
true orange so maybe time moves
faster instead of
slower could be what's the dilation how
do he make it back just going to skip
over that [__] just climbed out
[Applause]
okay D this is actually feeling like
sci-fi horror this episode this good
it's good [__] what is your rank in
serial number do you know where you are
what did what is pro operation what
flavor of Capri Sun is that give him
time to answer
questions a nice
plating isn't that kentaro's Mom yeah I
don't want to be racist though in case
I'm wrong all Japanese people are the
same I'm glad you said it
first someone needed to just say what
everyone's thinking
[Music]
here oh the Christmas cookie you doing
Japanese voice no he was he was a baby
voice doing a Japanese girl like what
are you doing right now on camera that's
my anime girl
voice
oh cold get me
build that's that's how we Americans get
[__]
done it's how we Americans deal with the
language barrier we just say what we
want louder we in a mon medical facility
you disappeared during operation
Hourglass in
1962 20 years ago he's having a Captain
America moment here yeah it's Dad a
punch karo's
Dad yeah it is
whoa
heri pocket knife oh nice stretch
Zoo what a great look on his face
[Music]
too wow cool I like this one this is a
psychologically disoriented
episode
1982 not bad that was cool
lonely scared people in
pain and do Terrible Things Monarch got
a lot of lonely scared people in pain
around it's a poignant
line that's why he has two
families
you are the best character you
are he knows too much now why do he want
his old job
back
a now you're just like your
dad
you must push
ahead feel the pain that's how you get
to
[Music]
acceptance
I what the
yeah what the hell just happened
contrast G that's called a choice I
don't know Capital C
sure
okay right it's a character Choice it's
diagetic sound I was like I thought it
was just is this what we're going the
mood of the sea that we bought this song
we should put it somewhere every time
Shaw's imploded another rip point we get
more gamma rays all over the world right
yeah big noisy chaotic and they're
getting stronger
Barnes not the first one that signal
remained constant so I crushed it down
so that I could see all of it look oh
when you zoom out there's a pattern
where where is it coming from there's a
rhythm they're in time somebody sending
us a message it's Morse code wait
someone sending a message so Shaw is
sending a message from Beyond I mean in
the from the realm yeah or maybe it's
Kate maybe she knows how to harness the
gamma because she's a random yeah rand's
are
special why is Monarch treating me like
I'm a prisoner no one's entirely sure if
you're safe no contagious or radioactive
or a Russian
plant they just want to know what
happened to you and how your survival
your age defies logic and Beyond logic
Beyond science Beyond Reason if I tell
you the truth you're just going to think
I'm crazy if you keep it to yourself it
was all for
nothing pulse
Rising play with time in this episode
whoa
nice that is a very cool POV whoa
ooh oh my God this should have been the
show way earlier I
know this is so
cool feel like we're actually exploring
and doing [__] now yeah it's whole
episode hey
man Nine episodes feels about right
finally get to some intrig so we began
playing
DVA walk all attempting to contact get
my Zach moris phone
out and then something happened
oh we encountered a massive unknown
terrestrial
organism [__] phenomen m erress like
some Zack Snider [__] yeah all we need
is like a throat singer
soundtrack oh this is scary next thing I
[Music]
remember W straight up a horror episode
feels like he's back on Black
Mirror who's here I was in the village
inside it there's a shrine they said
it's the boundary between the walls of
the living and the dead we found the
rift in there mythography so he was only
there for like a little bit yeah I guess
so monach is moving you to a secure
facility for observation and study oh
retirement home I think you'll be
comfortable there oh so he's there for
decades yeah they' just been monitoring
and probing him 300,000 years from the
crater of the civilization to the Moon
we lived with the Titans until you three
yeah
some Beast are best left undisturbed I'm
sorry a but you need that for your
pencils this is your legacy this is your
family business I buried that family in
three empty boxes the manness that
devoured my childhood but oh wasn't
Madness was fact then there was a choice
maybe that makes it w and what's his job
you know Lea's on a doctor he's just
here to talk with people yeah he just
kind of knows what Monarch's been doing
yeah everyone's always like you just
been around all this time I guess you
work
here pregnant M has another reason to
visit the ons pain
relief long speaking of pain relief Hill
forever
ill dude nurse Monarch it looks like a
retirement of they straight up slapped
him into a retirement oh
nice oh
oh no more pills for
[Music]
me oh my God yeah well now you
know and there it is yep nice K is
K it's a good idea to just scream in
this
place you will not not attract any
unwanted attention nope he ain't going
to become nobody's
snack I mean obviously Dr Randa
eventually found oh my god oh
Daddy
this guy's such an [__] I
know where have I heard that
before right right
yeah I get
it
say something of of value she's in the
thingy she went in the hole say say she
went in the
hole
oh this [__] is a heartbreaking holy
[__]
damn oh God you cry this way if it was
me my God godz always going to wake her
up
hey I've been waiting for you we made a
saw you eyeing me jump on my
back we're going to ride out of here
together
oh all the jokes guari killing at thisis
I know I'm happy for him my dude show
the the flip up yeah he's here man Jesus
Christ great scenes with Dad great
scenes with Mom whole episode killing it
I'm happy for him I'm here for
[Music]
it
oh that's not a
friendly but I feel like a friend going
to
save
whoa what is that Jim Hansen [__]
yeah it's like if a war was a
boore
a buiness that's so cool with the tree
trunks Fantastical and so
Elemental change my goddamn M I was just
doing this to be dramatic
hey you look different from everyone
here what's your
name oh
oh an arrow
yeah it's Hawkeye it's the grandma yes
yes yes I called it nice hell
yeah
oh let's go well I tell you damn I
didn't want that episode to end for once
that was surprisingly say might be the
best Legacy of Tim oh it's easily the
best since Legacy of Tim it's yeah it's
a real close one yeah it's hard to beat
Legacy of Tim but this was yeah quality
ass episode close it takes a lot to
eclipse the beauty of Tim and his
presence overall like a Tim episode
automatically shoots you to the top but
with everything else firing on all
cylinders and no Tim this was the best
could possibly
be not bad I'm happy oh wow it just took
forever to get to I'm all for buildup
but I feel like we could have gotten
here in a couple episodes got like
episode four or something or hinted at
some of this earlier yeah now I'm going
to do is just complain about this show
after getting a great ass episode all
I'm going to do is complain about why
was it the greatness here sooner yeah
going to yell at the show for not just
get it to the point faster even
greatness is negative on this
show uh yeah that was excellent that
that that was extremely gripping from
beginning to end that was extremely
gripping yeah um for starters canaro man
uh make a lot of jokes about his one no
performance and boy did he give
variations at first I was like all right
okay he gave a crying okay he
cried good good job it's good good and
then it just like he kept going
throughout the episode like oh my God
he's like still he's doing variations
it's not just repetitive and I believe
the trauma that he's currently
experiencing yeah yeah no there's a
variety here a lot of Anguish and
um I don't know now I'm beginning a
wonder is it is it just is he I don't
know who the actor is is he like
actually from Japan is he Japanese
and is it like just the handling of the
I mean maybe we're alone in the opinion
here I think it's just like just kind of
seems a little monotone and uh one note
when he's but I noticed like most of
this episode he was speaking Premier but
then again that first scene was in
English yeah so maybe it is just the uh
maybe it's the actual scenes they gave
him to work with in being directed here
yeah yeah I mean his Zach sent when he
speaks English suggests to me that he's
been speaking it for all of his life
probably like it it sounds to me just
off face value from watching the show
like he's probably an American actor who
speaks Japanese you know but but maybe
like I I don't feel as much like oh this
is a guy who's probably got a whole
other career in Japan who is being
brought over here doesn't matter he's
excellent he was excellent either way he
was excellent all the flavors all the
shades the scenes with Hiroshi and him
at the end I thought that was like that
was the kind of again it's that's the
kind of drama you want from show I was
like godamn I'm not going to cry but I
feel it but I feel it and and it and it
ties in well to everything we've seen of
the past we understand exactly how and
why H Hiroshi and canaro would be the
way that they are and respond to all
this the way that they do and and yeah
you you see what's easy to fix about
their situation but also you understand
intimately like the weird messed up you
know role models and and family lives
they all have to go on you know to form
all this and yeah just it felt tangible
and how trauma begets trauma and not
dealing with it see HT scared people you
know yeah the line that the that the mom
has um yeah it was it was quite poignant
but um so that and then you know just
getting to this aspect of what I'm
assuming is Hollow Earth uh just another
element to it or another section yeah
it's it's like it's the waiting room of
no it's like the world like you're in
different parts of countries and
continents geography and different uh
yeah environment and different foliage
and all that stuff yeah yeah so uh going
to that side of it and um I I think like
the way that's captured is really
mysterious and neat it doesn't it feels
it still feels big but again like how we
said during the by if you're listening
to Apple on Spotify we just watched PK
and stud uh yeah we we uh we really like
this one and when we went to the hollow
Earth I liked how it separated itself
from what we've seen from Godzilla
versus Kong nor does it feel like it's
it still feels like it's connected it
doesn't feel like a completely separate
entity you know like I love the the
lighting the different shades of the
colors and then even from going to where
Kate is to where Shaw and kiry Clemens
are you you get a sense of like the the
variations and also getting a little bit
of the creatures like I actually like
that creature that the one that was like
made out of bark and tree and
stuff all over it that was really cool
it felt very it felt very mystical and
uh different yeah and it feels like
primordial but of the earth it still
feels prehistoric you know yeah and it
feels like akin to various things that
you would see on the surface but yeah
Circa the Fantastical nature of you know
Kaiju and and yeah everything that we've
seen of the hollow Earth thus far but
more forly man like it was just a it it
knew its tone this time it really knew
its tone and I know there's a lot of
people who have been really loving the
show and for us it's been a real up and
down Journey from fine to is really good
to
board to's going on come on just get it
going yeah yeah it's been a and I and I
know there's a lot of people who feel
the same way we do too and um all we can
do is express our honest opinion here
but to me I'm like this is more of the
show that I I I never saw a trailer for
this show so I didn't know what to walk
into uh but seeing what they had on
their hands of what to play with this is
exactly like the marriage between past
and present uh 50s to present World um
mystery solving that I'm like yeah this
is the marriage I've been looking for
yeah it has that Twilight Zone quality
or that um God there's something there's
a better Touchstone but yeah it has that
quality of like something is off and
straight range and and mindbending and
forboding about all these things
happening it's like it's got a clover
fieldes I feel like you say what you
will about the various installments but
Cloverfield always has that thing of
like there's a
lurking ominous presence or even lost
has that where yeah there's just you
want to feel in a show like this like
there's mystery lurking around every
corner and like someone's always
watching and this episode had that where
it's like you they use POV very nicely
and I think they handled the stuff even
though like at times when they jump
around in the past it can be a little
bit of a moment to recalibrate your
brain and go like okay wait where are we
in the linear timeline but yeah when
they show them disappear into the Earth
and this lightning storm happens and
then we don't really see him until he
gets back and there's all that stuff to
wonder about I thought they actually
brought back the like PTSD flash Motif
in a way that worked again in a sense of
you're getting these intense brief
images of what happened when he was sent
down there during his first encounter
with this so it would be more fragmented
and and overwhelming in your mind and
yeah when they bring him back and you're
not even quite sure what year it is but
hero is is has aged Beyond you know sha
now like all that stuff was like a was
the right kind of disconcerting and yeah
you have all these people in these
hazmat suits and stuff and it's it had
all the aesthetic cool sci-fi stuff that
you want out of that and it actually
managed to grab and sell the tone and it
had drama or you know character beats
again like this is mostly a plot
oriented episode but the character beats
they chose made impact and they felt
proportionate and they felt like at
least for this episode appropriate to
complement everything else that's going
on well there's suspense and fear and
dread underneath the plot lines being
delivered yeah so they even though but
you know have some straight up character
scenes you know the SC between Karo and
his mom
in the living room was just about grief
every scene with a mom is just about
emotions how people are you know and
she's so natural which is great yeah uh
but the strain relationship side of like
when Shaw and do what is Hoshi uh when
when Lea and Hiroshi meet up with each
other and talk like I felt the the
distance in the T like I thought it was
it was placed nicely where you in the
beginning you established the
relationship between uncle and him and
you really get a sense of like the
little boy and his uncle who he loves
and then it cuts a years later and how
fragmented and how um fragile this whole
thing is I thought it was excellently
Illustrated in just the the fear of like
when he's like grabbing him like this is
your legacy I'm like oh my God this
whole all this [__] about this is your
legacy katyar this like it always felt a
little bit cheesy and a little forced
and and then here like no no I get it
now here makes sense yeah completely
made sense uh especially because it all
starts here and it's like this big gap
of where Everything's changed for Shaw
yeah well when you see Hiroshi you at
first think like you know he's with
Monarch so clearly he must have Arisen
the ranks but I thought that yeah you
could I thought they really nicely Drew
when he's talking about like you know
the family I buried them in three empty
boxes everyone told me they'd come back
and they didn't and like and that's a
human like it's cool cuz it's a human
thing of like these people were clearly
more married to their work than married
to look after you you know and there's
been that sort of detach with Randa in
or with Bill uh you know where it's like
do you didn't really care about having a
family dude but like you know with Kay
and with Shaw they seem very kind of
more intent on the kid and I felt the
weight of that here where it's like yeah
you would feel abandoned and even though
it's like monarch probably is this thing
for you where it's like the only way to
get any answers about why your life is
what it is but at the same time I can
totally imagine you not being happy to
be here and this being kind of a
traumatic thing to do that you just feel
like you just have to do cuz it's yeah
it is it is your legacy but I felt the
harsh side of that from just the body
language and the performance from the
actor who plays Hiroshi
especially um and and yeah like it again
it was a nice intermingling of sci-fi
cool [__] but also you know actual drama
that's appropriate for again the
universe that we're in yeah was shot
really cool too I think like every
single shot felt composed based off of
the emotion of the scene yeah and the
POV and and how to accentuate you know
the the the chaos and the you know
discovery of it all they did drag out
the reveal of how Shaw came I mean kind
of piec it together he went to Hollow
Earth and then he came back that's how
he decelerated his but kept feeling a
mystery then it solves it they explain
it in like 15 minutes yeah the more the
more Dred out to get to this answer I
get for narrative placement to get to
the point to to reveal it but I I do
feel that as a whole if this show does
get picked up for a season two you can
do some less beating around the bush
yeah there there there has been some
beating around the bush where it's like
it's pretty obvious from even for those
who really like the show uh just like
going through at least like feedback and
comments of what what really works yeah
yeah yeah all across the board for
everyone and like this was a perfect
encapsulation of like no this is what
the show had should have got could have
got into a lot quicker because this
actually feels like we are expanding on
the world instead of just filling in
some gaps like like in terms of like
where does it place in the monster verse
yeah whilst being focus on characters
that like the psychological Intrigue and
mystery build like and the Mystery
building and the World building of like
Hollow Earth and I'm not just more like
yeah oh that's how Apex came to be you
know or or just like why is Monarch like
I did it was funny and I I appreciated
this episode but there was a quality
with Monarch as an organization where
their their whole story is sort of like
all right we we did this experiment and
the Army is like we got to cut your
funding and no more of this then we're
going to do one more experiment and the
Army is like nah we got to cut the
funding man no more of this and it's
always like oh you guys still here how'd
that happened you know and that's sort
of like the the most that a lot of the
episodes have given you about Monarch is
sort of like well I guess you're just
good at sticking it out but but yeah it
it has felt like very small scale
expansion and like curiosity expansion
rather than this episode yeah feeling
like the that side of Monarch was
actually kind of neat and intriguing to
me here because it was complemented then
by a bunch of rewarding answers and
glimpses and intense moments and things
that yeah feel like you're getting a
broader picture rather than just like an
interesting artist rendering of a piece
of the map you've already seen and I
think what's cool about what they've
done with Monarch is we have essentially
focused on its Founders yeah you know um
oh my God I'm play on her name what is
uh K uh I it's like kako I think or
something like that I need to get her
full name but they call her K uh yeah
her
and um and and then of course uh Billy
Rands Bill Randa Jesus Christ yeah Bill
Randa every's name Bill Randa How Could
You Forget these classic characters Bill
Randa and Lee Shaw and and you watch how
they were pushed out and it's become
some other weird secret military Hub
thing of yeah weird side off the book
agency it's like Ray croc in the
McDonald's yeah yep that's what it is
man it's all about real estate that's
right yeah you you but you are watching
just how uh what what became of them and
the tragedy that befell them yeah H like
she's lost and Lee Shaw has just been
like sticking on retire like he
experiments this this phenomenon he
experimen Immaculate thing and was like
uh we got to bury this just put him in a
[__]
discard this guy put him in a box study
him but yeah yeah give him some pill
it's tragic it's tragic and I felt the
weight of that like that transition from
him just being like ejected and S sunken
into that chair and then feeling a sense
of hope with the monsters coming
out so his plan though is to shut it
down right like that is his plan is to
conceal it shut it downal the barriers
so that their world is their world his
world going to get all kinds of awoke
and once he sees mama oh yeah oh
Everything Will Change yeah and then
he's GNA be like I have to stay down
here so you have so many grandkids
yes yeah man they got a whole other
families to find down there Kate's going
to have like two daughter-in-laws yes
got so many other families down here
now yeah he can take he can follow in
hiroshi's Footsteps in the future past
while never aging and that's F like
that's a fun I guess just time just
humans just Pro seem like they don't age
at all or you age so slow I guess there
I guess time doesn't I don't think time
happens time yeah just to apply down
there cuz and I thought that was neat
like he's only gone for what seems like
a very small amount of time from his
perspective and like 20 years go by see
and that's what I mean by an expansion
on the go on the monsterverse world of
explaining what Hollow Earth because
like in in like
Godzilla like monster verse is so
separate from like Japanese God Godzilla
yeah where it's like nuclear radiation
and atomic bomb [__] you know and and it
he is like another world there's a
hollow Earth and I like that that the
Japanese side of Godzilla has become
very much like let's take a uniquely
like grounded view on what this could be
and and what commentary we can make and
the American side is like let's make
this as Fantastical and spectacular and
and mystery boxy as we can yeah so which
are cool they're two no it's great so
one doesn't just they don't just feel
like they're completely aping it I like
but the but but this expands on like the
hall earth side of things yeah in a way
that is truly interesting and I want to
go back to and I want to see more of and
I feel like you could do a lot with
yeah yeah yeah this was a great episode
this is Gen Never Too Late genuinely a
great episode I was invested in every
character scene I was invested in the
entire mystery the past and present
story lines were both awesome to look at
the visuals were Dynamite I felt the
suspense I felt the dread I felt the
unnerving um I I thought it was the
music was great the every frame was
excellent um yeah this was like a truly
great episode yeah only thing missing
was Tim not much Tim and lack of Tim and
if next time we could get uh an episode
for Kate like we just had for Hiroshi I
mean not Hiroshi uh kintaro then that
would
be legit I think we're going to get it
we probably will yeah the two of them
together explain how she survived yeah
and then neither of them have she
survived amongst the monsters yeah she's
cat as everine now she's out here couple
woman is is the ultimate woman she's the
ultimate badass Japanese scientist woman
FES to
America get manages to get her kid over
here here yes shunn by a bunch of
caucasians in government but still
manages to start crazy Top Secret Agency
Secret Agency get slung into Hollow
Earth manages to become a surviving
Warrior for however long it feels like
she's probably been down there for like
2 hours but like in her time but yeah
for 40 years for the rest of us or
however many 50 60 years the hell is she
yeah I'm excited to find out like like
as much as that that does happen at the
end and you're like okay like this this
I could see this being cartoony I'm
still excited because she is one of my
favorite characters on the show and yeah
I'm excited to see her second Arrow
showed up I was like come
here yeah and it's good there's uh Lee
and K are together separated and then
the two I know ka's like I love Kate
Kate for some reason I need to find her
I love her that one time we bonded I
love her I love her so much yeah was
good should put her in the thumbnail yes
yes we
should put everybody who only had like a
minute's worth of screen time you think
think we can't go that spoiler we can go
even more
spoiler there's no Center image there's
just a description in text of what
happened in the most exciting
moments yeah yeah great design work
great uh you know yeah I love this
through time I love this felt like what
I heard severances I haven't seen I
haven't seen any Seance I'm like this
feels like what I hear Apple TV is like
yes little bit great compelling
television little bit mindbending some
imagination good production values
quality acting some decent writing as
well oh gosh yeah cuz I I've just felt
like it's so much of this has been not
singing But D not been as you would hope
yeah yeah this was this was great this
was a bit mindbending good way that
[__] time yeah man we got there
eventually and hey maybe the finale is
going to be D I'm sorry but guys nothing
can
beat
Tim no there's a reason Legacy of Tim
will always be the top epis this is
definitely a better Episode by a lot
like this is for sure a better episode
yes but uh Tim is just is my favorite my
personal favorite one I give my favorite
moment in terms of character flavors Tim
is the character you want he has all the
qualities that are the most enjoyable
and appealing and the performance is in
line with all that so like the strength
of just him solely but yes if we're
talking everything else this is a better
episode nothing beats that Tim moment
for me well because I don't love
anything as much as I love Tim but like
I didn't I wasn't sad or or feeling
slighted that we didn't spend any time
with him in this episode yeah no I love
the sci-fi horror of this yes yeah I
like that we're a monster show but we
can't really afford that so we're going
to cut the clips of that one movie and
we're going to do a lot of wheel
spinning in the meantime your sci-fi
horror show then yeah man that's what
you want from a show like this you're
you're yeah Black Beer adjacent in your
yeah genre bet be a genre be a [__]
genre yeah yeah be a genre that's all we
are instead of some weird biguous can be
be a genre yeah if you're not going to
commit to being a the drama that you've
tried to be at least commit to being a
genre or two yeah man that is great and
maybe do all three and that'll be great
oh yeah I I think they did it at this
time I think they did all right guys
well what did you think about it we got
oh my god oh oh we got like a minute
left on got so much time to fill up on
this card no we don't all righty guys
well we're going we're going to end this
and uh thank you for being here leave
your thoughts down below Legacy of
canaro
continues
[Music]
peace